en el principio no había nada
estaba el universo sin orden y vacío y
las tinieblas cubrían la superficie del
abismo no existía la noción de tiempo ni
de materia y de repente hubo luz
esto es el big-bang en un instante
aparecen las partículas subatómicas
durante los siguientes 380 mil años
estas van a ir combinando se para crear
iones que son átomos con carga eléctrica
aparecen los núcleos primordiales como
el hidrógeno y el helio los elementos
más ligeros y más comunes del universo
al final de esta etapa el universo está
lo suficientemente frío como para que
estos iones que estaban cargados se
vuelvan se vuelvan en átomos neutros
aquí es donde pasa algo increíble
el universo emite una luz que aún
podemos ver hoy y que conocemos como
radiación del fondo cósmico
esta imagen es una foto del universo a
sus 380 mil años de edad y es increíble
que aún lo podamos ver como vemos en
esta imagen hay regiones del espacio que
están marcadas en rojo que tienen unas
temperaturas más elevadas que sus
alrededores estas regiones son el
indicio de las fluctuaciones que
aparecieron en nuestro joven universo
donde gradualmente se va a empezar a
acumular la materia para que aparezcan
nuevas estructuras complejas van a
aparecer nuevas fuentes de luz y de
radiación nacen las primeras estrellas
empiezan a aparecer los nuevos objetos
hermosos del cosmos como las galaxias
los cúmulos de galaxias
y todas las evoluciones naturales de las
primeras estrellas que nacieron las
enanas blancas las supernovas las
nebulosas los agujeros negros
son cada uno de ellos objetos hermosos y
fascinantes del cosmos y cada uno de
ellos es un universo en el mismo algo
que explorar algo que entender
y por qué
porque no se nos fascina tanto la
historia del universo porque nos fascina
tanto estas complejidades que surgen
después del big bang
porque es nuestra historia es nuestro
origen
es lo que consideramos nuestro mito de
la creación más antiguo que cualquier
mito que encontremos en la literatura
entender de dónde viene la materia del
universo es entender de dónde venimos
nosotros como decía el gran astrofísico
carl sagan estamos hechos de polvo de
estrellas
imaginaros que ahora os digo cuando
estamos mirando al cielo nocturno
estamos mirando en el pasado que vais a
pensar le están mintiendo esta chica
pues no es que cuando miramos cada vez
que miramos al cielo nocturno es como
viajar en el pasado porque pues porque
la luz de las estrellas tienen que
viajar cierta distancia para llegar
hasta nosotros por lo tanto cuando
miramos a una estrella la estamos viendo
en el momento en el que emitió su luz
como ejemplo se tarda un poco más que
cuatro años para que la luz de proxima
centauri una de las estrellas más
cercanas a la tierra llega hasta
nosotros o sea que proxima centauri se
podría morir y no nos daríamos cuenta
hasta después de cuatro años y igual
pasa con estrellas que están más lejanas
no nos daríamos cuenta hasta 100 o 300
años
imaginaros si tanto tarda la luz que es
lo que más rápido viaja en el universo
en llegar hasta nosotros cuál debe ser
la escala del universo nuestro cerebro
ni siquiera puede imaginarse la
inmensidad de este ente
y como cada entidad gigante hay rincones
y espacios del universo que aún no
conocemos pero de los que nos planteamos
millones de preguntas
muchos piensan que explorar las
preguntas más grandes del cosmos es
hacer ciencia inútil piensan que es
hacer ciencia que no tiene aplicaciones
en el mundo real
pero alguna vez os habéis parado a
pensar los resultados que puede dar la
pasión de un científico por saberlo todo
por más inútil que sea
en su libro el valor del saber inútil
habrán flexner explica como la búsqueda
de las respuestas más fundamentales ha
llevado a la aparición de campos de la
ciencia que han resultado tener
aplicaciones inimaginables para la
humanidad
quien diría que la aparición de la
física cuántica ayudaría a la creación
de smartphones y ordenadores décadas
después
y es por esta razón que hoy quiero
hablaros de uno de los grandes misterios
del universo hoy quiero llevarlos de
viaje a un sitio que nunca habéis estado
hoy quiero llevar a este viaje al centro
de una estrella
imaginemos lo que debe estar pasando en
el centro de las millones y millones de
estrellas que hay en el universo
las estrellas básicamente son bolas de
gas y como os debéis imaginar ya en el
centro tienen temperaturas muy elevadas
gas temperatura elevada pasan procesos
físicos fenomenales
y es los núcleos atómicos del gas a
temperaturas elevadas comienzan a
combinarse entre ellos mismos para crear
núcleos más pesados esto es lo que
conocemos como fusión nuclear
y es de esta manera que de los elementos
más ligeros como el helio y el hidrógeno
que se crearon al principio del big-bang
aparecen otros elementos más pesados
como el oxígeno el nitrógeno o el
carbono el aire que estamos respirando
alrededor nuestro se creó en una
estrella igual que el carbono del que
estamos hechos
es impresionante pensar esto es que de
verdad estamos hechos de polvo de
estrellas
y también la fusión nuclear es la razón
por la cual las estrellas tienen su
propia luz
la fusión nuclear libera energía por lo
tanto las estrellas
al hacer este proceso también liberan
energía pero esto solo pasa hasta cierto
punto y es este este punto es cuando se
llega a la producción del hierro
cuando una estrella llega a la
producción de hierro la fusión nuclear
ya no es energéticamente favorable para
esta estrella es decir ya no se puede
producir de manera espontánea por lo
tanto la estrella para de fusionar los
núcleos que hay dentro de ella y se
enfría ya no emite luz ya no emite
energía así que no se va enfriando al
enfriarse la estrella
ya no puede mantenerse y por lo tanto se
acaba colapsando en ella misma
y aquí es donde pasa algo también
fascinante acabamos de experimentar la
muerte de una estrella
esta imagen que veis aquí quién pensáis
que es
pues esto no es nada más que una
supernova que es cuando una estrella
muere expulsa las capas exteriores de la
estrella hacia afuera creando esta nube
de colores y en el centro de este esta
nube quedará el núcleo de la estrella
que aún se sigue colapsando en el mismo
quién diría que algo tan bonito es una
muerte
quiero dejar claro que este este destino
sólo está reservado a estrellas que
tienen una masa 20 veces más mayor que
la masa del sol si una estrella es más
ligera tiene otras muertes
bueno pues volvamos al centro de esta
nube al centro el núcleo de la estrella
se sigue colapsando y se va haciendo más
pequeño y más pequeño cada vez tan
pequeño que llegará un punto en el que
la materia está tan densa en ese punto
que aparecerá uno de los grandes
misterios del universo
ahí nacerá un agujero negro
ahora os debéis estar preguntando y
porque ha salido un agujero negro así de
la nada y otra pregunta por qué se
llaman agujeros negros es que son negros
de verdad o no
pues para responder esto vamos a mirar
hacia la fuerza de la gravedad
la gravedad es una fuerza que depende de
la masa y de la distancia que estamos
del objeto en cuestión
cuando el núcleo de una estrella se va
condensando
este núcleo llegará un momento que será
tan denso que la gravedad que ejerce
hacia sus alrededores será muy muy alta
y llegar a un punto en el que esta
gravedad será tan elevada que hasta la
propia luz que es lo que más rápido
viaja en nuestro universo ya no podrá
escapar de este punto y entonces qué
pasa si no escapa la luz de este punto
como lo vemos
es que no lo vemos y por eso se llama un
agujero negro
además de eso esto nos muestra porque
sabemos tampoco de los agujeros negros
porque son fenómenos que son muy
difíciles de reproducir en un
laboratorio y además es que no los
podemos observar directamente pero esto
ha cambiado en los últimos meses
el pasado mes de abril unos científicos
consiguieron tener esta imagen de un
agujero negro
esta imagen es un fruto de una
colaboración científica que se llama
aventura esencial de scope en la que
varios radiotelescopios de alrededor del
mundo se juntaron para hacer una imagen
a la misma región del espacio donde
sabían que hay un agujero negro al mismo
tiempo para así poder producir una
imagen que tenga la misma resolución que
si tuviésemos un radiotelescopio de la
talla de la tierra
y bueno después de dos años trabajando y
trabajando consiguieron esta imagen
y es increíble porque es un paso
adelante para la astrofísica a saber que
otros descubrimientos saldrán de esta
imagen
a lo mejor os haya inspirado a vosotros
oa los más jóvenes de la audiencia a
explorar más allá de nuestro mundo en
galaxias más lejanas y contribuir al
siguiente gran descubrimiento de la
humanidad oa lo mejor os haya inspirado
para completar el puzle que es nuestro
mito de origen y la historia del
universo sea lo que sea el universo y
sus misterios están ahí para que
desvelamos sus secretos y el mundo está
a nuestros pies gracias
[Aplausos]